in my opinion the greatest player of all  time is Michael Jordan I think the  greatest player of all time is LeBron  James players from different eras you  know that use bought at different parts  of the game so I think you got to give  your respect all that great display of  all with all the time he's Kobe Bryant  LeBron just cuz I've always kind of  watching them so I mean I feel like he's  most one of the most dominant players of  all time  I think Michael Jordan is the greatest  player of all time you know he does it  all so I think he needs to go for sure  and he went to North Carolina so that's  it self question I would have to go with  my karora i think that LeBron James as  the greatest player of all time the  greatest player of all time me is Kevin  Durant  that's the controversial grass we're out  of time my goods or next question next  question  [Music]